LOOK AT OF GOING IN THERE.
THERE'S SOMEBODY CONTACT.
HE GETS A STICK TIME FOR ONE
MORE RUSH.
THERE S A DEFLECTION.
HE IS STRONG ON THE SKATES.
THAT IS THE SAVE BY FREDERIK
ANDERSEN.
SAME EXACT LINEUP FOR
ROD BRIND'AMOUR.
WHY CHANGE A  IS NICK COUSINS.
THERE WAS A SAVE  GOOD TO SEE
LIFE FROM CODY
CIRCLE.
THEY GO TO THE NURSE SITE.
THERE TONY DeANGELO, HE IS LOOS
WE TOLD YOU THERE TEAMS
IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY
COUNTRY MUSIC.
HOW COULD ANYONE JOHANSEN.
HE STOLE IT.
HE ELEVATED THE A EVENTS.
DOWNLOAD YOUR PROFILE.
NASHVILLE IS TRYING . NASHVILLE
THE PENALTY.
THE PREDATORS WILL START THE E
GLASS.
NASHVILLE WILL REGROUP QUICKLY.
THAT WAS SAVED PHYSICAL GAME,U
THERE IS RYAN JOHANSEN TRYING
HOW YOU DEFEND THE ONE GOTHE BE.